et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Alexis Corbière bonjour bonjour Merci
beaucoup ce qui nous écoutent meilleurs
vœux également député la France
insoumise de la Seine-Saint-Denis en
étant enfant pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale bonjour Fabrice le Cerdon
bonjour
les bras les journaux régionaux de tout
l'Est de la France on va évidemment
parler de cette réforme des retraites
puisque c'est aujourd'hui qu'elle est
présentée en conseil des ministres avec
ses Corbières Emmanuel Macron a dit hier
soir que le Parlement pouvait aménager
la réforme Gabriel Attal hier matin dans
le Parisien s'est dit ouvert aux
modifications vous avez le sentiment que
le gouvernement vous a entendu
ah je crois qu'on a assisté jeudi
dernier à une des plus grosses
manifestations depuis 30 ans c'est ça
qui fait bouger les choses et vivre tous
ceux qui sont allés manifester gloire à
vous à ce peuple qui se lève non mais
c'est important parce que je suis
parlementaire
je pense aussi au Sénat le travail qui
va être fait va être sérieux mais ce qui
va changer les choses si si l'ensemble
de la population dont les études
d'opinion nous montre que 9 salariés sur
10 sont opposés à cette réforme 68 ou
70% de la population donc au bout d'un
moment il y a une question qui est
d'ordre démocratique et moi je voudrais
insister là-dessus parce que nombre de
mes amis ont déjà argumenté pour quelle
raison économiquement on pourrait faire
autrement comment il y a rien d'urgent
mais il y a un problème démocratique et
j'aimerais que le Président de la
République l'entende où est le mandat va
me dire c'était dans son programme
certes mais il a été élu au second tour
dans un rejet de Madame Le Pen il s'est
exprimé au soir du second tour en disant
ce vote m'oblige je sais je le cite de
mémoire que nombre de nos compatriotes
qui ont été pour moi n'ont pas voté pour
des idées et à l'Assemblée nationale on
voit bien que son parti ses amis députés
n'ont pas obtenu une majorité parce que
notamment sur cette question de la
retraite les Français ils ont obtenu une
majorité relative mais ils ont obtenu
une majorité le président de la
République dit le projet a été validé
lors des législatives ça c'est un sujet
intéressant parce que chaque fois ça
fait des polémiques et de bon matin on
va pas s'engueuler mais c'est quoi une
majorité relative c'est-à-dire est-ce
que les amis de Monsieur Macron sont
s'il dépendent un texte sont
majoritaires à l'Assemblée réponse non
d'accord donc ils ont besoin de trouver
des points d'alliance mais ils ne sont
pas majoritaires alors qu'il était
précédemment pour quelle raison ils ont
perdu beaucoup de députés sans doute
aussi en raison de leur programme ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que ce
président de la République doit faire
attention à une chose c'est que si quand
quelqu'un est opposé à l'extrême droite
qu'on invite les électeurs à dire vous
n'êtes pas totalement d'accord avec moi
mais le rejet m'a même Le Pen ou de
l'extrême droite doit amener à voter
pour moi si une fois que le tour de
passe pas c'est passé en leur dit en
vérité c'était mon programme qu'est-ce
qui va se produire que les gens ne vont
plus aller voter pour faire barrage à
l'extrême droite donc monsieur Macron et
c'est déjà ce qui a eu lieu dans
certaines élections c'est à dire que ce
qui était un des suites notamment notre
histoire douloureuse de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale il y avait une tradition
politique qui consistait à dire je suis
en désaccord avec ce candidat mais je ne
souhaite pas l'extrême droite si
Monsieur Macron brutalisent le peuple et
lui dit en vérité vous étiez d'accord
avec moi même si jamais je n'ai obtenu
une majorité sur mes idées sa roi des
conseils
sur les 65 ans là on est à 64 et
français
et le Conseil constitutionnel est alerté
il y a quelque chose qui a qui dansait
déjà un outil anti démocratique c'est
l'article 47.1 je fais simple qui est
une forme de 49,3 nouvelle formule si je
puis dire c'est la première fois dans la
Constitution qu'on va l'utiliser à
l'occasion d'un texte sur le projet de
loi de finance sécurité sociale
rectificatif mais je dis que normalement
pour quelle raison même si je suis
opposé au 49-3 c'est 47 ans c'est que il
y a un impératif budgétaire qui consiste
à dire constitutionnellement à dire il
ne faudrait pas qu'un espèce de shut
down financier et que le gouvernement
peut accélérer les choses mais sur la
question des retraites il n'y a pas de
raison de brutaliser et d'accélérer les
choses limite le temps des débats et
bien je prends le pari que le Conseil
constitutionnel pourrait invalider cela
en disant on peut discuter de la réforme
des retraites mais d'aucune manière de
la même façon sur des questions
budgétaires il faut qu'elle a au 31
décembre des décisions soient prises
rien ne le justifie et je crois savoir
que Laurent Fabius a déjà alerté
là-dessus donc qu'est-ce que ça montre
qu'en fait il y a il tordent la
Constitution parce que ça n'est pas fait
pour ça alors actuelle d'ores et déjà
nous sommes le système est excellentaire
on nous dit dans les années prochaines
il y aura peut-être un problème mais
j'ai un problème qui peut être réglé
assez facilement c'est l'heure de 2 à 3
% déficit donc il y a pas d'urgence moi
je suis un opposant à cette réforme je
ne vois pas pourquoi les Français
devraient travailler deux ans de plus
cela produira des pensions plus basses
cela produira de la précarité c'est mon
opinion mais de toute manière d'abord
entendez-moi comme parlementaire je dis
il n'y a aucune raison d'utiliser des
articles ne sont pas faits pour ça et je
dis monsieur Macron en utilisant cet
article vous portez la marque d'une
brutalisation et je crois que le Conseil
constitutionnel vous le rappellera et il
est possible que tous débat soit jugé
anticonstitutionnel le 49-3 ou le 47 ans
n'est pas fait pour faire passer un
rallongement de la durée de retraite ce
n'est pas vrai c'est n'est pas une
question budgétaire c'est une question
politique c'est quoi c'est un acte
d'autorité du président de la République
oui parce qu'il a peur d'être mignon on
y revient c'était le point d'épargne nos
discussions parce qu'il a peur d'être
minoritaire à l'Assemblée nationale
pourquoi ne laisse-t-il pas le temps du
débat il y aura 10 ou 20 article je ne
sais pas nous allons le découvrir cet
après-midi régime spéciaux surtout âge
de la durée de travail discutons-en je
suis un opposant je dis aujourd'hui
qu'en fonction des conditions de travail
de nos concitoyens il n'y a aucune
raison de les faire travailler deux ans
de plus d'ores et déjà le problème des
pensions qu'elle est-il elles arrivent
trop tard et elles sont trop basses
travaillons là dessus ça n'est pas la
piste mais c'est un débat parlementaire
pourquoi le brusquer dire en 15 jours
faut régler l'affaire on va parler du
fond mais puisque vous êtes venus sur la
stratégie parlementaire on va écouter
Olivier Véran le porte-parole du
gouvernement il était hier l'invité de
BFM et il vous interpellé sur votre
stratégie parlementaire nous souhaitons
évidemment que ce débat parlementaire et
les Français sont très attentifs et nous
aussi à ce que les députés puissent se
saisir de ce texte le travailler et le
modifier et c'est sûr que si vous avez
un groupe qui arrive et qui vous balance
des dizaines de milliers d'amendements
pour vous empêcher d'examiner le texte
alors là je vais vous dire une chose
s'il y a 70 000 amendements vous auriez
4 ans de débats au Parlement
c'est-à-dire qu'on ne serait que ça dans
le pays pendant 4 ans on arriverait pas
au bout donc je dis vraiment au groupe
d'opposition laissez les parlementaires
débattre ils ont besoin de le faire nous
avons besoin qu'il le fasse et les
Français l'attendent qu'est-ce que vous
répondez le dessin animé le personnage
qui court et au-dessus de la falaise il
mouline là c'est pareil là ces petites
jambes elles tournent parce que personne
c'est de quoi il parle qui sait qui sait
qui empêche le débat parlementaire c'est
lui vous ai dit que j'allais déposer
75000 ans
du débat c'est à dire normalement sur si
on a du temps pour discuter nous on a
toujours dit qu'on prendrait et on fera
en sorte que le débat est Dieu pour que
les Français puissent se mobiliser là
l'heure actuelle ça n'est pas la
stratégie que nous allons utiliser nous
allons créer les conditions d'un débat
donc vous nous dites ce matin il y aura
pas mis l'amendements par député de la
France
répété même quand monsieur vérante est
un homme informé dis ça hier il le sait
donc c'est un menteur donc ça sera quoi
la stratégie d'amendements il y aura des
amendements pour que la discussion ait
lieu moi je vous souhaite notamment avec
mes amis qu'on puisse en particulier qui
est le moment de débat dans le très peu
de temps qui reste je vais revenir mais
qu'au moins on puisse avoir la
discussion sur la question de la durée
de ton travail d'accord parce qu'on va
voir je vous dis aujourd'hui texte de 10
article texte d'un article je n'en sais
rien et permettait que nous bâtissions
notre stratégie parlementaire en
fonction de ça qu'est-ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que si ça commence sur
les régimes spéciaux évidemment
l'intensité du débat nous mènerons la
bagarre parce qu'il est hors de question
toucheurs rising session mais je veux
qu'on arrive dans le peu de temps que
nous avons à parler notamment et montrer
de quelle manière c'est une AB de
vouloir faire travailler des Français
plus longtemps mais d'abord et avant
tout celui qui fait de l'obstruction par
le montant il s'appelle là notamment
puisqu'on parle de lui Olivier Vérand
c'est Madame borne c'est Monsieur Macron
qu'est-ce que j'appelle obstruction
parlementaire l'article 47 ans je sais
que vous êtes une chaîne qui est précise
là-dessus mais répétons le ça veut dire
que quoi qu'il arrive à partir où le
texte est présenté en 50 jours pour que
ce soit réglé dans le mouvement 15 jours
à l'Assemblée ça part au Sénat et ça
revient à l'Assemblée même s'il n'y a
pas de majorité mais ami concitoyens qui
m'écoutait acceptez-vous un régime
politique dans lequel une réforme aussi
fondamentale que celle qui va vous
demander de travailler deux ans ne soit
même pas adopté majoritairement à
l'Assemblée nationale si je vous
décrivais ça vous diriez monsieur
Corbières vous me décrivez là une
société autoritaire et bien c'est la
France d'aujourd'hui je dis à Monsieur
Macron et le gouvernement autoritaire
je vous l'ai dit je pense que c'est une
utilisation abusive du 47 ans je forme
les vœux que le Conseil constitutionnel
le rappelle ça n'est pas fait pour ça et
de toute manière oui c'est un des traits
autoritaire la Cinquième République
pourquoi moi je suis pour une sixième
république c'est un régime présidentiel
qui peut brutaliser la représentation
parlementaire danger moi je le dis on a
bien compris que la logique
d'obstruction sortait un petit peu de
vos plans en revanche ceux qui font de
l'obstruction j'aimerais que vous le
disiez c'est Madame borne fait de
l'obstruction nous un parlementaire il
est là pour discuter à l'Assemblée moi
j'en ai assez qu'on me dise vous faites
de l'obstruction parce que vous allez
déposer derrière
et nous ne créerons les conditions que
ce soit pas réglé en 15 jours
faites-nous confiance en revanche en
revanche vous appelez à manifester vous
appelez au soutien de la rue oui avec
l'idée d'embarquer un petit peu plus les
jeunes des étudiants les lycéens
d'abord le cœur de ceux à qui nous
adressons et qui était là jeudi c'est le
salariat je dis c'est une journée à mon
avis qui inquiète particulièrement le
gouvernement c'est que ceux qui sont à
les manifester ne sont pas seulement
pardon les secteurs traditionnels de
ceux qui manifestent je pense notamment
à la pointe avancée du salariat comment
dirais-je souvent dans la fonction
publique où il y a un taux
syndicalisation ce qui moi impressionné
jeudi c'est qu'il y avait des
entreprises privées qui sont des gens
qui ne manifestent jamais ce que j'ai
trouvé émouvant même c'est des gens qui
disent je n'ai jamais manifesté de ma
vie mais je viens c'est le petit
commerçant qui dit moi je viens c'est
l'employé d'une entreprise privée où il
n'est pas simple de se mobiliser c'est
pourquoi je comprends les organisations
syndicales qui saluons-les sont unis et
qui lancent des appels de mobilisation
qui permettent y compris à des gens qui
ont perdu une journée de salaire
éventuant de recommencer et en
particulier quand le débat parlementaire
va avoir lieu donc oui la jeunesse est
sollicitée pour vous répondre
belle manifestation également mais de
moindre ampleur évidemment
est-ce que vous allez en refaire
d'autres comme ça où est-ce que
désormais vous allez vous ranger
derrière les mobilisations syndicales
c'est-à-dire que d'abord je vais
utiliser le mot de ranger même si c'est
pas disciplinaire mais c'est elle qui
donne le tempo les organisations
syndicales et il va de soi que sans
faire la Genèse quand le 21 a été décidé
il y avait pas encore la date
interditale du 19 donc tout ça
s'articule bien le samedi est une
journée où on peut manifester sans se
mettre en grève ça allait bien surtout
des jeunes maintenant on a cette journée
du 31 je rappelle que les organisations
syndicales disent aujourd'hui qu'à
partir d'aujourd'hui il peut y avoir des
des grèves qui se déclenchent dans
certains secteurs donc ça veut pas dire
on fait rien jusqu'au 31 et après nous
dans notre rôle qui là il y a une
articulation j'essaie de bon matin je
vais pas être technique entre vous trois
techniques ou du moins il y a les
organisations syndicales qui font leur
boulot et le politique doit continuer
avec vous je vais faire plein de
meetings à travers la France newpest et
mes amis en font pareil les agendas des
uns et des autres sont chargés déjà la
semaine dernière il y a eu Japy c'est un
gymnase ou une grande à Paris il y a eu
Olympe debout voilà ce que je veux dire
c'est juste ça veut dire qu'elle est
fine appellera plus à manifester dans la
rue vous laissez ça aux organisations
syndicales mais j'exclus pas si par
exemple la jeunesse aussi lancé un appel
que nous prenions en 2017 mais que ceux
qui va donner le temps pour dans les
semaines qui viennent les gros moments
de mobilisation c'est l'intersyndicale
et il nous attendons à ce qu'elle le
fasse et nous lui faisons confiance mais
ça veut pas dire que d'un seul coup nous
disparaissons la France insoumise doit
parler y compris pour nourrir le débat
vous savez dans une entreprise quand
vous discuter avec les gens nous sommes
tous unis sur une question de
l'opposition et le retrait de ce texte
mais après il faut discuter parce que
faut d'autres solutions moi je veux
améliorer les retraites moi je vois bien
qu'il y a des gens qui ont tous des
petits
trucs en position on va évidemment
parler du fond pour finir sur la
formulaire Philippe Martinez a dit ne
pas exclure des journées d'action
pendant les vacances de février vous
cautionnez ça je cautionnerai tout ce
que veut dire à l'intersyndicale je suis
derrière elle je pense qu'elle parle
juste de Monsieur berger à Monsieur
Martinez en passant par Monsieur
Souillot la FSU ils ont raison c'est
précieux l'unité syn local donc de toute
manière à l'heure actuelle mon rôle de
parlementaire ça va être de faire le
travail à l'Assemblée nationale les
amendements mais c'est aussi de dire à
tout ce qui nous écoutent suivez les
consignes de l'intersyndicale et
notamment le 31 soyons massifs pour dire
que c'est tout un peuple il y a comme on
dirait il y a tout un peuple il y a
quasiment un homme seul monsieur Macron
à côté c'est un problème démocratique et
ça donne de la puissance à nos débats
parlementaires et justement allez on va
parler du fond hier dans le Journal du
Dimanche Olivier du soft affirmé qu'il
n'y aurait pas de perdants à cette
réforme qu'est-ce que vous dites à ça
que je n'ai pas exemple à partir du
moment où vous travaillez deux ans de
plus si vous êtes perdant et tout le
monde va devoir travailler plus
longtemps ça va entraîner d'ailleurs
j'avais déjà dit ça le passage de 60 à
62 ans a amené à ce qu'il y ait plus de
gens qui soient bénéficiaires du RSA je
veux dire ça va aussi c'est 62 à 64
amenés à ce que des gens qui n'ont pas
la totalité leur trimestre qui sont dans
des cari arrachées n'y arriveront pas
donc il y aura une baisse des pensions
ce sera mécanique il y aura des gens qui
vont être fatigués il y aura des gens
qui vont bénéficier moins de temps de
l'âge à la retraite savez-vous que entre
la réforme Monsieur Sarkozy je crois
qu'il était en 2010 à l'époque il y
avait une moyenne de 25 ans de vie après
le départ à la retraite aujourd'hui
autour de 24 ans et tout est prévisions
nous disent que là on va être à 23 ans
ça c'est de la perte peut-être que pour
monsieur duceau qui ne voit que des
tableaux Excel et des chiffres ça n'est
rien mais la vie ça existe le temps que
l'on a dans ce 3e temps de la vie c'est
rien de à 3 ans et bien moi je dis que
c'est fondamental va bénéficier plus aux
travailleurs modestes qui a des
améliorations des petites tensions qui a
des améliorations pour pour les
carrières longues qui a des
améliorations pour les congélateur au
moins autant de temps il n'y aura pas
d'amélioration voir plus longtemps
là-dessus on peut pas mentir je veux
dire y compris les 1200 euros qui sont
répétés à l'envie par comme si c'était
une grande surprenant 7200 euros brut un
vérité 1150 net ça va une petite
augmentation c'est toujours ça de bon
d'une centaine d'euros mais qui tu étais
déjà dans la loi Fillon on n'a pas
attendu mais qui n'était pas mise en
application par les mêmes de plus 5 ans
d'accord
mais pourquoi depuis 5 ans il ne le
fait-il pas puisque c'est ce qu'il faut
faire et je rappelle les gens pour
gagner 100 euros ils vont devoir
travailler 2 ans de plus et tous les
chiffres sont là pour nous démontrer que
ces deux ans sont particulièrement
supplémentaires sont particulièrement
durs pour ceux qui travaillent le plus
dur vous savez pour un cadre il y a des
tas de gens et je me range dans cette
catégorie je veux dire sans doute que
quand vers 64 65 ans si la santé m'a été
préservée je peux continuer à être en
activité vous aussi enfin je ne veux pas
parler à votre nom mais quand on a des
travaux plutôt intellectuels c'est même
le moment de la vie où on se sent le
plus en ayant amassé de connaissance
mais pour beaucoup de nos concitoyens le
corps ne suit plus est-ce qu'on peut
parler de l'âge en bonne santé 62,7 ans
je crois pour un homme et déjà la
moyenne donc si vous rallongez à 64 ans
les gens seront physiquement de plus en
plus abîmés donc on est là face à
quelque chose qui est fondamental d'où
vient cette idée que face aujourd'hui à
la situation dans un pays qui a accumulé
les richesses il n'y aurait aucune aucun
effort qui serait demandé aux
entreprises pour éventuellement
augmenter les cotisations de 0,7% par
exemple pour pour une nouvelle raison ne
se mettrait pas un terme à nos
exonérations de cotisations de notre
système des retraites ça coûte quand
même deux à trois milliards chaque année
d'euros là dessus aucun effort n'est
demandé la seule chose qui est demandé
aux travailleurs c'est travailler plus
et avec cette difficulté pardon
d'enfiler les arguments un peu comme les
colliers de les perles d'un collier mais
vous savez d'ores et déjà on a un
problème c'est qu'à 55 ans beaucoup de
gens sont déjà sont dans un problème
d'emploi c'est à dire que les
entreprises mettent un terme mais
justement sur la question des seniors le
gouvernement ne va pas assez loin qui
est fait c'est une nouveauté avec la
menace d'ailleurs de sanctions pour les
entreprises qui ne qui n'ont pas
calmez-vous menace de sanctions nous
parlons d'un index non qui ne créent
aucune aucune sanctions il dit on peut
retravailler sur cette question de
l'index des sanctions bon là vous allez
demander des sanction vous dites il faut
des contraintes il faut des sanctions
financières on fera le travail mais le
fondamentalement la question chacun
comprendra que ce n'est pas parce que
vous repoussez l'âge de la retraite
de toute manière que ça va créer une
situation qui va être favorable aux
salariés il faudra plus de temps pour
arriver jusqu'à l'âge de la retraite
nécessairement des gens n'y arriveront
pas parce que c'est déjà le cas et donc
il y aura une pension qui sera à la
baisse à l'arrivée un dernier mot
puisque des députés modernes veulent
proposer un allongement de la durée de
travail hebdomadaire ils veulent passer
de 35 heures à 35,5 heures ça fait 30
minutes de plus par semaine qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de cette idée mais où
est le sens de l'histoire enfin je moi
je non mais discutons-en je suis dans un
pays qui est riche qui accumule des
richesses les Français ont constaté cet
été le thème des surprofis des grandes
inégalités c'est quand même le sujet
aujourd'hui Monsieur Bernard Arnault
gagne en 6 secondes qu'un salarié je
crois gagner en une vie ah non de
travail enfin on peut discuter de ça des
inégalités est-ce qu'on peut revenir
j'avais déjà évoqué devant vous à des
grands des grandes idées le partage des
richesses on produit des richesses la
productivité des travailleurs français
tout de même on n'est pas un pays
secondaire la productivité a augmenté
etc et est-ce que ce qui nous est
proposé élection après élection c'est
travailler plus longtemps sur la vie
travailler plus dans la semaine
quel but je veux dire pourquoi vous
savez on n'est pas que des bêtes de
somme nous ne sommes pas que des gens en
situation de productivité notre capacité
à vivre à aimer à se cultiver c'est
aussi quelque chose qui est précieux
même si c'est pas marchandisé est-ce que
pour discuter de ça ou est-ce que
j'apparais comme un hippie mais il y a
pas qui vient les cheveux longs ne
voulant rien faire non j'ai seulement
envie d'une société juste avec un
partage des richesses un partage du
temps et pas l'idée que tout ce que nous
produisons profite à une minorité chacun
n'a pour ambition qu'éventuellement de
travailler plus ou plus longtemps je ne
suis pas d'accord on va parler du
pouvoir d'achat oui on va parler du
pouvoir d'achat le gouvernement
réfléchit à panier anti-inflation les
prix bloqués plafonnés sur 10 produits
première nécessité ça va dans le bon
sens selon vous oui on va regarder en
détail c'est un peu cocasse parce que
quand nous leur avons proposé ça de
bloquer des prix de première nécessité
on nous a dit c'est impossible quasiment
c'était la Corée du Nord que nous
proposions nous étions votre proposition
pardon ils ont retenu on va voir moi je
veux dire
une grande distributeur de vendre une
vingtaine de produits
coercitif on va voir moi je vous dis
quand on mène une bataille politique
j'entends
qu'on en soit qu'on soit Pacifique qu'on
essaie de régler nos problèmes il y a
pas une grande tension en exagérant pas
la violence mais en fait il y a des
batailles idéologiques qui sont
importantes donc et qui permettent
qu'après il y a des qu'on puisse
l'emporter sur le plan de la loi moi
quand on met des idées depuis le début
nous les portons avec la France
insoumise Jean-Luc Mélenchon qu'il faut
bloquer des prix de première nécessité
qu'on nous dit c'est impossible et que
progressivement on en vient à dire parmi
la grande idée après six mois de retard
et le fait que l'inflation non seulement
est de près de 6% mais en vérité de 12
13% pour des produits si on me dit on va
demander à avoir des prix pourquoi pas
je demande à voir dans la réalité ce que
c'est la qualité des produits est-ce que
vraiment c'est efficace dans quelles
conditions mais je veux dire déjà
idéologiquement nous marquons le point
mais que de temps perdu c'est ça qu'il y
a de plus triste l'autre actualité hier
c'était cette grande journée pour
célébrer les 60 ans du traité de
l'Elysée au lave Scholl cet été à Paris
avec Emmanuel Macron Emmanuel Macron qui
a entretient un peu le flou sur la
livraison de Charles Leclerc à l'Ukraine
il a dit hier rien n'est exclu est-ce
qu'il faut livrer c'est Charles Leclerc
à l'Ukraine moi je pense qu'il faut
aider le peuple ukrainien alors quand je
dis ça c'est commençons par l'essentiel
Poutine et l'agresseur faut-il le
répéter mais parfois paraît-il que je ne
dis pas à mes amis à ses clairement il
est l'agresseur il a déclenché une
situation d'une grande pension faut
aider le peu plus craignant et il faut
que les troupes russes quittent le
territoire ukrainien une fois que l'on a
dit cela on doit bien sûr apporter notre
aide y compris la Crimée
moi je serai pour que
j'en arrivais là
des initiatives de paix qui soient
prises dans lequel on puisse mettre bien
sûr
l'Ukraine devra être entendu mais
l'agresseur usse russe aussi c'est le
propre à de négociation de paix même les
agresseurs doivent participer à la
sortie et que il y a une discussion
politique qui puisse avoir lieu
diplomatique dans ce cadre-là que
demande monsieur Poutine quels sont les
lignes rouges fixées par les ukrainiens
et comment la communauté internationale
éventuellement la France peut essayer de
trouver une solution pour qu'au plus
vite les armes s'arrêtent ce que vous
mettez est un point de discussion est-ce
que les Ukrainiens considèrent que c'est
la condition absolue sans quoi la guerre
continuera et que ça signifierait même
une offensive allant jusqu'à ce que la
guerre se poursuive même sur le
territoire russe etc moi ce stade ce que
je veux dire c'est pas une manière de
je ne veux pas premièrement je ne suis
pas nous ne sommes pas en responsabilité
ce que fait la France nous apportons une
aide est-ce que dans quelle mesure faut
la calibrer on va éviter moi je pas de
désaccord fondamental avec ce qui a lieu
parce que je ne sais pas le détail et
que dans certains points de vue cherche
pas toujours à le savoir enfin du moins
il y a des choses qui sont sensibles par
contre ce que je souhaite c'est que nous
nous rentrions pas dans une spirale dans
lequel à l'arrivée nous soyons nous-même
un des premiers protagonistes d'une
guerre avec la Russie dans la dedans
ça nous ferait rentrer dans cette pièce
nécessairement mais faisons-le de telle
manière que ce soit une aide matérielle
n'est pas une participation au conflit
je sais que certains voudraient plus
mais je dis nous n'avons rien à gagner à
participer à cette guerre qui peut avoir
une dimension mondiale ça ne signifie
pas pour autant que l'on capitule devant
Poutine cela me semble même être
l'inverse je pense qu'après il faut
continuer des sanctions financières
économiques vis-à-vis de la Russie
notamment de tous ces oligarques russes
on en parlait beaucoup au début du
conflit puis on a un peu oublié il me
semble que ils ont certains intérêts
aussi en France sur lequel on pourrait
continuer un peu plus à s'en saisir moi
j'en suis là je pense qu'il faut prendre
des initiatives diplomatiques et pour
que au plus vite les armes arrête
vous êtes inquiet de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en Ukraine vous pensez qu'on
peut aller vers une troisième guerre
mondiale oui non mais je objectivement
on a des puissances la réussite une
puissance de premier plan on peut avoir
une mécanique vous savez moi j'apprends
j'apprenais ça à mes élèves la Première
Guerre mondiale c'est déclenché dans une
mécanique ou au départ qu'est-ce que je
veux dire qui aurait pu imaginer que la
scène de l'archiduc à Sarajevo peut
entraîner une guerre mondiale et il y a
un truc domino
pardon mais le temps ce film j'aurais
posé deux questions politiques notamment
sur ce qui se passe du côté du Parti
socialiste vos alliés de la nuque ou
Olivier fort a donc été déclaré hier
vainqueur dans la c'est un Broglio le
plus total Nicolas Mayer Rossignol son
adversaire ne reconnaît pas sa défaite
et ne reconnaît pas le résultat est-ce
que tout ça ça affaiblit la nuque
l'autre jour j'avais fait en commentaire
disant que je souhaitais la victoire du
candidat qui défendait le plus la nuque
et certains socialistes m'ont dit ne
vous mêlez pas de nos débats je peux
comprendre de certains points de vue
donc je me mêlerai pas de leur débat
maintenant je souhaiterais évidemment
que ils arrivent à trouver une solution
et que effectivement comme vous l'avez
dit ce qui m'intéresse surtout c'est que
nous continuons sous cette forme inédite
qu'elle a nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale donc j'espère que
leur débat arriveront à atterrir comme
on dit un peu familièrement et que nous
continuerons à agir ensemble à agir
ensemble socialement la quelques heures
la bataille des retraites agir ensemble
électoralement je suis assez favorable à
ce que nous le retrouvions encore sous
des formes d'union à l'occasion des
échéances
le résultat terrible comme vous dites il
y aura quand même la moitié des
militants socialistes qui auront voté
pour le candidat qui est un peu opposé à
la nuque quand même est-ce que ça
affaiblit
le malin parce que y compris des gens
qui sont proches de Monsieur Meyer
rossignol m'ont dit que notamment des
sénateurs qui sont ici m'ont dit qu'ils
n'étaient pas opposés à la nupestre donc
c'est un peu compliqué parce qu'il y a
le totalement nupes et lui dire le nupes
mais pas exactement la même type de
nuptes dans les deux candidats c'était
madame Geoffroy qui portait vraiment une
ligne totalement hostile elle a fait un
score tout à fait bas donc je pourrais
aussi après tout soyons optimiste dire
que ces deux candidats qui sont pour
l'Union pas avec la même intensité mais
je pense que ce que porter monsieur fort
était plus clair mais surtout ils vont
en débattre leur congrès à lui à
Marseille ce week-end et j'espère qu'au
plus vite ils arriveront à trouver une
solution il me semble quand même que il
y a
un vainqueur mais là encore je veux pas
en dire trop mais surtout qu'on continue
à agir ensemble c'est la seule chose qui
nous intéresse oui parce que tout le
monde a bien ses soucis à la France
insoumise aussi c'est pas ça vous aviez
un conseil politique la semaine dernière
auquel vous n'avez pas assisté
Eric Coquerel était sur splato vendredi
il indiqué que selon lui il y avait
encore des améliorations qui pouvaient
être apportées des imperfections qui
pouvaient être gommer dans
l'organisation actuelle de la
je suis comme lui je pense que j'ai dit
même dans la presse qui est un peu
inédit de ma part des remarques et des
critiques je pense qu'on peut faire
mieux comme dirait Jean-Luc Mélenchon
faut y travailler
Eric notamment Coquerel avec d'autres il
y a un petit groupe de travail pour
faire des propositions allons-y c'est
quoi l'intérêt plus l'unité de la France
insoumise sera renforcé plus elle sera
donnée à voir c'est à dire que un
mélange d'expérience de plus jeune ne
plus expérimenter d'histoires commune de
sensibilise commune plus là il fit sera
forte plus la nuit Pesse sera fort c'est
à dire que nous sommes quand même le
moteur de cette union plus la nuit pèse
sera forte pluie il me semble que ça
aidera à l'unité syndicale et l'unité
syndicale unité politique pourra
permettre au peuple de se mobiliser plus
facilement me semble-t-il pour faire
reculer le gouvernement ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que la vie des
organisations bien sûr que c'est
important maintenant je pense ce serait
une erreur de vous parler au mois de
janvier de cuisine interne à la France
insoumise à l'heure où on agresse le
monde du travail pour faire travailler
deux ans donc je réserve l'intensité de
ma parole dans ma vie interne ça veut
pas dire que je n'en pense pas moi si je
puis dire mais on comprendra que il y a
un temps pour tout vous savez et c'est
comme quand ton jardin il y a une saison
où il faut planter et puis après vous
pouvez faire ce que vous voulez
supplanter votre gazon actuellement ça
poussera pas et quand il y a des idées
il y a des moments où il faut un peu les
mettre de côté là c'est le moment de la
bataille des retraites je me consacre je
me concentre là-dessus merci
Fabrice on passe au club des territoires
on reparle de la réforme des retraites